trade is good for business and promotes
bilateral relations but what do germans
think about TTIP the proposed eu-us free
trade agreement this is a unifier it'll
be good to have something like this
because German American relations are
very important to both sides so anything
that can improve that makes sense yeah
Alison was this for best on cotton it's
torture Nazi Germany is a very
export-oriented nation and we have to
make sure it stays that way but we also
want to maintain the quality standards
that we have here in Europe in Germany
in particular we must make sure they
don't fall by the wayside enters fate I
think it's good as it promotes the
economy fifty-five percent of Germans
pulled think that the transatlantic
trade and investment partnership is a
good idea just twenty-five percent
reject the notion twenty percent have no
opinion take common standards for
foodstuffs what do germans think about
that ninety-four percent the vast
majority want food standards that
conform to german regulations just 2%
favor adopting us legislation stinkin
solution as far as food technology and
quality are concerned I think our
standards are much higher and also more
environmentally friendly and sweet
Wiggly tongue is your annoyance than
that but with no I prefer to see new
standards the German ones aren't enough
and the Americans use so many hormones I
wouldn't take theirs either Devon what
is helping his name Chancellor Merkel
and President Obama have a year to work
out the details in 2015 TTIP is supposed
to be a done deal